the small town of Boston in the eastern
England has long had closed
international links in the early 17th
century pilgrims started out from here
for the United States today migrants are
coming to Boston mainly young people
from Eastern Europe see big miev is from
Poland he's an instructor at the town's
karate club when the weather's good he
trains with his polish friends outside
on the edge of town our main purpose is
the South development for the heart
karate training we always try to be a
better every day then day before and
tomorrow we'll try the same we will try
to be better than today keep moving
forward that's big neves approach to
life he and his wife Agnes came here 13
years ago my son Patrick was born in
England they started off working in a
factory but now both have jobs in
management and like many of their
friends they've bought a house here work
hard as much as possible safe as much as
possible some of them they will be back
to Poland I know a lot of my friends now
they settled here they've got own houses
here are they called England home really
around ten percent of people in Boston
now come from Eastern Europe
overall there's some three million EU
migrants in Britain far too many so the
euro skeptics one reason they want
Britain to leave the EU is to stop
further migration on the European Union
exit the European hey people have been
drawn here because of our high rate of
of benefits we earned those benefits we
earned the right we reinvested in
ourselves that's why this country is a
great country what can I lose oh we lost
we've lost a lot what can we gain back
our industries are gone it's not Britain
no more is it no it's too much a mixed
bag isn't it tis but not go into that
and we're and we're attracting too many
people yes for the wrong kind the EU
opponents are popular here many Britons
believe the e use policy of free
movement of labour is wrong I hope is
that the EU implant I hope those it's an
artificial political constructs what we
have now we're face to turn is in this
country one is Islamic fundamental
terrorism the others and the terrorism
sorry the tyranny of a European
bureaucracy which is imposing rules and
regulations upon us we have little
control over
so what would a brexit mean for Boston's
polish community as big Nia and his
family come to st. mary's church every
week mass is now also held in polish
here many members of the congregation
are worried they say the brexit debate
has stirred up resentment against them
although they have helped to make Boston
prosperous because we came here with
education who is culture and that people
is ready to work they pay taxes and I
guess I think we we have to do that we
are enriched at this is this country the
EU opponents are out in force on the
streets they say the EU migrants that
are already in Britain should be allowed
to stay but they want more controls
introduced to restrict the flow of
future immigrants even Agnes agrees that
not everyone should be allowed into
Britain we never ever claimed anything
we work hard so if you want to work hard
and there is a place for you here you
you can just find a job and work but if
you think that you will come here and
you will be claiming the benefit so I
think it's a mistake to be honest Agnes
ands mcneff want to stay in Boston and
work for good relations between the
Polish community and the rest of the
town in his karate club big knee F works
with children from 10 different nations
community integration is possible and
for all of us including British people
will be better for everybody if all
Europe will be United England is made up
from immigrants it's not only the
England the whole word is changing
actually right now and all the time so
we have to be prepared both agree that
Britain would be worse off without the
migrants from Eastern Europe and Boston
like many small English towns with
suffer both economically and culturally
you